[Musik]
bund und länder verlängern den teil
shutdown bis zum 10
januar in corona hotspots baden
württembergs gilt nachts künftig eine
ausgangssperre
wie gefährlich sind querdenker die
protestbewegungen könnte zum
verdachtsfall für den verfassungsschutz
werden
ein freund der deutschen frankreichs
frühere präsident des kaders ist im
alter von 94 jahren gestorben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 7 sport gibt es
auch in dieser woche von norbert lehmann
als wunder dürfen wir die zweite welle
der korona infektion sie fällt höher und
stärker aus als erwartet die bisherigen
einschränkungen haben nicht zu einem
nennenswerten erfolg geführt
und so überrascht auch nicht dass sich
bund und länder gestern entschieden
haben die schärferen regeln noch bis ins
neue jahr hinein beizubehalten
genauer bis zum 10 januar bis dahin
bleibt die gastronomie geschlossen und
auch die kontakt beschränkungen gelten
mindestens so lange mit kurzen ausnahmen
an weihnachten und silvester deutschland
sei noch sehr weit entfernt von den
zielwerten begründet die bundeskanzlerin
wie nature berichtet markus söder in
passau die stadt der hot spot unter den
hotspots eine instanz von fast 500
passau ist aktuell im lok dar
für söder reichen die maßnahmen
bundesweit nicht locker und leid hat
einen teilerfolg jahre heißt es wächst
nicht mehr exponentiell
so weit so gut so weit so schlecht
es reicht einfach nicht aus die
gesamtzahlen gehen mich drunter aus dem
norden kommen bessere nachrichten
hamburgs erster bürgermeister besucht
eine baustelle fern im zentrum und kann
vermelden
in der stadt sinkt das erste mal seit
anfang oktober die sieben tage instituts
unter 100 und trotzdem verlängert
hamburg alle maßnahmen
wir wollen nicht in diesem juli effekt
kommen wir werden in einem sehr sehr
sicheren bereich uns bewegen müssen
bevor wir in hamburg die maßnahmen da
kann
und aller voraussicht nach wird es nicht
vor dem zehnten januar sein
manuela schwesig hingegen will nicht
ausschliessen vorzeitig zu lockern
mecklenburg vorpommern hat
vergleichsweise niedrige
infektionszahlen ein optimismus den sich
die wenigsten bundesländer leisten
können und beim hoffnungsschimmer impfen
bremst die bundeskanzlerin
wir müssen durch den winter durchkommen
ohne darauf zu setzen zu können dass wir
in
große masse schon solch ein impfstoff
zur verfügung haben und von frühjahr an
wird sich das dann weiterentwickelt
kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten wollen
sich erst anfang januar wieder treffen
sollte die hütte brennen sagt angela
merkel wörtlich dann auch er und die
hütte brennt jetzt schon in etlichen
landkreisen um im bild der kanzlerin zu
bleiben
dort gibt es nun zusätzliche ausgangs
beschränkungen etwa in bayern und in
sachsen
ausschlaggebend ist dafür eine hohe
sieben tage incidents ab einem wert von
200 sollen die menschen in baden
württemberg jetzt grundsätzlich nachts
zu hause bleiben betroffen sind derzeit
drei kreise und die städte heilbronn
pforzheim und mannheim und steuerte ist
jetzt auch unser reporter anton ja nie
nun kann man am abend sowieso schon
nicht ins lokal oder in die kneipe gehen
anton warum dann zusätzlich noch dieses
ausgehverbot
es herrscht masken pflicht hier in
mannheim aber es hat nicht den erfolg
gebracht den man sich gewünscht hat und
die zahlen im sieben tage schnitt pro
100000 einwohner sind deutlich über 200
die schrillen die alarmglocken auf jeden
fall statt und gesundheitsamt haben
erkenntnisse dass sich die meisten
mannheimer bei privaten kontakten
angesteckt haben und das will man jetzt
unterbinden mit diesen nächtlichen
ausgangs beschränkungen ja so versucht
man die zahlen in griff zu bekommen
die mannheimer sollen sich jetzt bis zum
14 dezember nicht mehr sehen nicht mehr
besuchen in der nacht von 21 uhr bis
morgens um fünf da hofft man dass die
zahlen passen es gibt natürlich auch
ausnahmen bei diesen ausgangs
beschränkungen berufskrankheit soziale
betreuung tierwohl oder notfälle aber
fadenscheinige ausreden die wollen
polizei und stadt polizei und stadt
nicht akzeptieren wer dagegen verstößt
riskiert ein bußgeld von 100 euro im
wiederholungsfall sogar mehrere hundert
euro danke für die informationen anton
ja nie in mannheim
der blick auf die zahlen das
exponentielle wachstum der
ansteckungszahlen ist gestoppt
stattdessen bildet sich ein sockel das
robert koch institut meldet 22.000 46
neuinfektionen seit gestern 479 menschen
starben in verbindung mit kobe 19 und
das rk ii fürchtet viele weitere tote
denn vor allem in alten und pflegeheimen
verschlechtert sich die lage
volker dutschek berichtet corona im
altenheim eine horrorvorstellung auch
für die angehörigen von patienten dieser
einrichtung im baden-württembergischen
neckargemünd und 80 der 90 bewohner
haben sich infiziert 13 senioren sind
gestorben
ein beispiel von vielen die hohe rate
von altenheimbewohnern an den krone
opfern nach dem robert-koch-institut
sorgen
diese meldedaten legen nahe dass die in
altenpfleger im eingeführten
präventionsmaßnahmen bisher nicht
vergleichbar erfolgreich in ausbrüchen
verhindert ausbrüche verhindern
dazu zählen mehr abstand hygiene bessere
schutzmasken schnelltests luftfilter von
33.000 infizierten patienten in
pflegeheimen starben fast 5300 das sind
16 prozent bei den 18 1000 infizierten
pflegekräften liegt die sterberate
dagegen bei 0,3 prozent eine weitere
alarmierende zahl rund ein drittel aller
corona toten im land hat zuvor in einem
altenheim gelebt ein weiteres sorgenkind
schulen und kitas dort werden
infektionen oft spät erkannt
schnelltests durch lehrer könnten da
helfen die idee kommt bei
gewerkschaftern nicht gut an
mein eindruck ist dass herr spanier mit
einem schnellschuss reagiert hat warum
auch immer
die erwartung kann nicht erweckt werden
dass von morgen an das wurde ja gesagt
von morgen an in allen kitas und schulen
getestet werden kann
wer soll testen woher kommen die test
wer soll sie bezahlen das sind fragen
die herr spahn noch beantworten muss
viele fragen die bis morgen eigentlich
geklärt werden sollten
anders als in deutschland können die
menschen in italien weihnachten nur
unter starken beschränkungen feiern
grund die weiterhin hohen corona zahlen
zuletzt wurden dort fast 1000 tote
binnen 24 stunden gemeldet
vom 21 dezember an sind reisen zwischen
den einzelnen regionen verboten über die
festtage darf sogar niemand die städte
verlassen
ausnahmen gelten nur für dringend
notwendige fahrten wie den weg zur
arbeit
verschiedene corona impfstoffe stehen
kurz vor der zulassung
europa hat sich hunderte millionen dosen
gesichert ebenso andere
industrienationen wie die usa um auch
den entwicklungsländern zugriff zu
verschaffen benötigen die vereinten
nationen viele milliarden euro zur
stunde diskutiert die un-vollversammlung
wie die verteilung weltweit geregelt
werden kann
johannes hano
mit einer schweigeminute gedachten die
vereinten nationen zum auftrag des
sondergipfels der bislang fast 1,5
millionen toten weltweit in seiner rede
bekräftigte un-generalsekretär gutes
erneut dass solidarität in diesen zeiten
eine frage des überlebens sei ich habe
immer wieder gesagt dass ein cockpit 19
impfstoff ein globales öffentliches gut
ist dass allen menschen zugänglich sein
muss
aber es gibt immer noch eine
finanzierungslücke von 28 milliarden
dollar allein für die nächsten zwei
monate 4 43 milliarden in rekordzeit
haben internationale pharmakonzerne
impfstoffe entwickelt um der krise herr
zu werden und dabei überall auf der welt
getest jetzt aber steht die welt vor
einer großen ethischen frage es wäre
doch zum beispiel unfair wenn 80 prozent
aller deutschen geimpft werden aber die
hochrisikogruppen oder das
krankenhauspersonal in südafrika keinen
zugang zu dem impfstoff hätten wir vor
für die anderen die pandemie schon
vorbei die ersten impfdosen werden
ausgeliefert aber sind vor allem die
reichen industrienationen die den markt
schon jetzt über monate praktisch leer
gekauft haben eine gerechte verteilung
des impfstoffs liegt in weiter ferne
daran wird auch dieser gipfel nichts
ändern auch wenn ihr viel von
internationaler solidarität die rede es
beschlossen wird auf diesem gipfel
nichts wenn am ende handeln die staaten
wie er sich leisten können dann doch vor
allem im eigenen nationalen interesse
zurück nach deutschland viele aktionen
gegen die korona maßnahmen organisiert
eine initiative die sich selbst quer
denken nennt in ihrem umfeld tummeln
sich bekannte extremist innen und
selbsternannte reichs bürger auch
deswegen wird der ruf nach dem
verfassungsschutz immer lauter unter
anderem heute im stuttgarter landtag die
initiatoren während sich andreas linke
es ist eine mischung von strömungen die
sich bei den corona demos zeigt friedens
flaggen reichskriegsflagge hinweise auf
verschwörungs mythen auch wenn eine
führungsfigur der querdenker der
stuttgarter michael ball weg sich von
extremisten distanziert eine friedliche
bewegung aber so klar ist der abstand
möglicherweise nicht bei big und die
querdenker trafen sich zum beispiel mit
dem november mit polizeibekannten reichs
bürgerin auch mit einem selbst ernannten
könig von deutschland für christian
kreis der anlass sich loszusagen
mir ging das zu weit ja sich mit einem
im königreich deutschland mit 1 peter
den ersten zu treffen das war für mich
so eine linie wird es erwischen da kann
ich nicht mehr mitgehen vorgänge die
auch die verfassungsschutzbehörden auf
die bewegung schauen lassen
das sonder weise finden wir in der
zwischenzeit eben bei vielen querdenker
organisatoren auch bundesweit bekannten
personen genau diesen reichs bürger
sprechtext rehm ist ische parolen die
sprüche der sechst verwalter und reichs
bürger werden von teilen des
demonstrationsgeschehen es übernommen
das zeigt dass die strategie der
extremisten auch ein stückweit
erfolgreich ist so werden die rufe
lauter der verfassungsschutz möge
genauer hinschauen nicht auf friedliche
demonstranten habe auf extremisten gute
den querdenken einsamkeit ist ein
problem das sich in der korona pandemie
noch weiter zuspitzt es leiden vor allem
alte kranke und auch zunehmend menschen
mit behinderungen
schon vor corona habe sich jeder dritte
von ihnen einsam gefühlt so der
paritätische wohlfahrtsverband corona
habe nun barrieren und ausgrenzung noch
einmal verschärft dort ferber hat
recherchiert plexiglas und abstand erol
hrubesch arbeitet jetzt damit immerhin
die werkstatt für menschen mit
behinderungen war lange geschlossen
und corona das ist hier noch schwerer zu
begreifen als ohnehin schon
da hat einfach an ihr so das geht es
nicht mehr weiter
doch bleibt so für ewig standard vor
fiebermessen maske abstand das
funktioniert alles erstaunlich gut hier
aber manches geht weiter nicht
weihnachtsfeier ausflüge sport und vor
allem offene gesichter und berührungen
als möglichkeit der kommunikation auch
weil ja viele die hier arbeiten nicht
unbedingt in der lage sind sich gewählt
sprachlich auszudrücken
da fehlt uns an verfasserin zugang zu
den menschen ist halt das intellektuelle
vermögen nicht unbedingt einer zeitung
zu lesen ist neben stoff gibt es ist
unheimliche sorge dass das nie ein ende
haben könnte diese ganze pandemie die
angst der menschen hier ist groß und
auch die einsamkeit viele leben in
wohnheimen
dort gelten besonders strenge regeln in
diesem kölner heim gibt es inzwischen
schon eine zweitinfektion das heißt auch
für andere immer wieder quarantäne
und für die ist auch das thema infektion
was bedeutet das wenn man gar keine
krankheit hat und deshalb zu hause
bleiben zu müssen nicht nachvollziehbar
wir setzen uns ja sehr für ein
selbstbestimmtes leben der menschen ein
und wir erfahren gerade so zu sein die
höchste stufe der fremdbestimmung das
leben mit vielen neuen regeln
hier fällt es besonders schwer es sind
quälende stunden im gerichtssaal für die
angehörigen des ermordeten kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke drei
unterschiedliche versionen der tat hat
der mutmaßliche mörder stefan ernst
bereits zu protokoll gegeben
entschuldigung
heute nun war die familie am zug ihre
fragen gingen direkt an den
hauptangeklagten dessen antworten werfen
nun neue fragen auf susanne santana war
in frankfurt dabei
für die familie von walter lübke war es
heute einer der wichtigsten prozesstage
sagte sie auch eineinhalb jahre nach dem
mord an ihrem ehemann und vater walter
lübke treiben sie viele fragen um und
sie fordern vollständige aufklärung vom
hauptangeklagten stefan ernst
dabei ging es heute vor allem darum was
weiter lücke in den letzten sekunden
seines lebens gesagt und getan hat ob es
noch ein gespräch gegeben hat ob er eine
möglichkeit gehabt sich zu wehren
ob er vor allem wusste was auf ihn zukam
das ist für das verarbeiten durch die
familie von einer unglaublichen
bedeutung in der tat wären habe sich
walter lübke nicht mehr können sagte
stefan ernst heute mehrfach finger bei
seiner einlassung an zu weinen er habe
walter lück erschossen
aber markus h sei dabei gewesen in der
letzten sekunde seines lebens so ernst
habe walter lübke in die augen von
markus h geschaut
die bundesanwaltschaft ging bislang
nicht davon aus das haar konkret an dem
mord an walter lübke beteiligt und in
der tat nach dabei war
wie ernst es heute sagte insoweit müssen
wir dann auch erst sehen vielleicht
wirklich erst am ende der beweisaufnahme
welche der vielzähligen versionen und
auch überhaupt was doch was wir davon
glauben können
die familie von walter lübke hält die
aussagen von stefan ernst für
überzeugend und glaubt daran dass markus
h in der mordnacht dabei war
das gericht will stefan ernst nun noch
einmal ausführlich befragen
mit einem urteil ist deswegen erst im
januar zu rechnen
großer europäer modernisierer mann der
freiheit so würdigten politiker weltweit
valéry giscard d'estaing
frankreichs ehemaliger präsident ist im
alter von 94 jahren an den folgen von
corona gestorben
von 1974 bis 1981 war er stabschef und
brachte frankreich bedeutende reform mit
kanzler helmut schmidt legte er
grundlagen für die heutige eu beide
verband eine lange freundschaft an einen
außergewöhnlichen staatsmann erinnert an
arbeit
als valeries kataster präsident wird
gratuliert dem helmut schmidt als einer
der ersten der franzose und der deutsche
ein politisches tandem
gemeinsam bringen sie europa auf den weg
zur union zu einer gemeinsamen währung
er war ein überzeugter europäer wir
verdanken ihm dass wir heute den euro
haben
seine vision für europa für mich war das
ein wahrgewordener traum für evtl
möglicherweise gibt ihm sein geburtsort
diesen länder versöhnenden weg schon vor
1926 kommt er in koblenz zur welt das
einzige was mich interessiert ist der
wandel hat der mann der mitte schon zu
beginn seiner politischen karriere
gesagt seine reformen wie etwa die
legalisierung der abtreibung oder die
absenkung des wahlalters auf 18 jahre
prägen die gesellschaft valéry giscard
d'estaing wollte ein moderner präsident
sein auch wenn es manchmal nicht leicht
war hat er immer den kontakt zum
französischen volk gesucht
bei der beerdigung des ex präsidenten
jacques chirac sein letzter öffentlicher
auftritt heute trauert frankreich wieder
um einen präsidenten und um einen großen
europäer der schnitt und jetzt zum sport
und zum norbert und zum biathlon weltcup
im finnischen kontiolahti der hat denise
herrmann bei den frauen im sprint als
beste deutsche platz fünf belegt bei den
männern war olympiasieger arnd peiffer
erfolgreicher er wurde zweiter sein
erster podestplatz in diesem winter
abgekämpft nach zehn kilometern an
peiffer zufrieden mit seiner leistung
ich meine oberste priorität am
schießstand durchzukommen und das ist
mir gelungen und das freut mich vor
allem der sprint-olympiasieger von klang
in dieser saison mit neuem gewehr am
start das ist immer eine große
umstellung und erfordert gewöhnung heute
bleibt er fehlerfrei zweimal auch seine
laufleistung im tiefen schnee von konto
lachte überzeugt antifa ist nah dran am
ersten saisonsieg schneller und zwar
knapp 14 sekunden ist notar aus norwegen
auch er fehlerfrei beim schießen
dritter mit einer strafrunde sein bruder
johannes tennisball der antifa ist rang
2 der 36 podestplatz seiner karriere
benedikt doll wird achter bvb-stürmer
und earl in holland wird nach
muskelfaserriss wohl bis jahresende
ausfallen
entwarnung dagegen bei abwehrchef mats
hummels die verletzung gestern beim
vorzeitigen champions league achtelfinal
einzug durch das 1 2 1 gegen lazio rom
hat keine folgen
ja und rb leipzig hat die chance aufs
achtelfinale gewahrt nach dem
spektakulären 4 zu 3 last minute sieg
gestern abend in istanbul
alexander salot ragt heraus in der
nachspielzeit das langersehnte erste tor
des norwegers für leipzig ist das
entscheiden so zum 4 3-sieg gegen bashir
istanbul
am ende die drei punkte die sind wichtig
und wir sind glaube ich über den
gesamten spielverlauf ist auch nicht
unverdient
doch es hätte gar nicht so knapp
ausgehen müssen zweimal geht leipzig mit
zwei toren in führung durch paulsen und
hier noch die lokale in der ersten
hälfte in der 66 minute dann das 3 1
durch daniel doch irgendwann kw schied
er schon das erste tor für istanbul
erzielte trifft noch zweimal auch zum
ausgleich per freistoß
dann kommt solo zum 4 2 und macht
leipzig baldigen achtelfinaleinzug
möglich und das was so wird ja danke
vorsicht beim wetter vor allem im westen
wird es heute nacht glatt wie es morgen
weitergeht dazu gleich mehr von katja
honnefer das war es von uns schön dass
sie dabei waren
claus kleber freut sich auf sie um drei
viertel 10 und wir sind morgen wieder
für sie da punkt ziehen einen
entspannten abend wünschen wir machen
sie es gut
[Musik]
meine damen und herren drei teams über
westeuropa und für uns ist dieses in der
mitte das spannendste das zieht morgen
über frankreich in richtung deutschland
macht aber bevor es deutschland
erreichen die biege richtung nordsee und
streift uns am rande
so gibt es schon in dieser nacht schnee
schneeregen und gefährlichem glatteis
legen hier ungefähr zwischen dem
sauerland und dem schwarzwald machen sie
sich darauf gefährlich glatte straßen
gefasst im osten ist es zum teil klar an
der donau bildet sich nebel bei
temperaturen zwischen minus zwei und
minus sechs grad im westen bleibt es ein
wenig milder und morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen bei 1 bis 6 grad im
nordwesten werden es sieben bis neun
grad genauso wie am alpenrand das ist
dort dann dem südföhn geschuldet aber
auch in norddeutschland gibt es morgen
stürmische wind an der nordsee das ist
allerdings ein südostwind in
norddeutschland bleibt es meist trüb und
da zeigt sich auch mal die sonne
vor allen dingen richtung sachsen
gefährlicher ist es wieder im südwesten
deutschland ist ungefähr zwischen der
rhön und dem oberrhein da kann es noch
weitere schneeregen fällung glatteis
regenfälle geben
am alpenrand dagegen strahlt die sonne
mit föhn und in den nächsten tagen geht
es winterlich weiter mit viel schnee in
den alpen am sonntag schön haben noch